hot mugshot guy Jeremy Meeks spotted  kissing another woman  [Music]  the 33 year old model who rose to fame  after his smoldering mug shot took the  internet by storm was photographed  getting extremely cozy on a yacht off  the coast of Turkey with Topshop heiress  Chloe green over the weekend the two  were seen kissing passionately and  sitting on one another's laps but the  world's sexiest felon is still  reportedly married to wife Melissa Meeks  and has been for eight years the couple  shared two equally gorgeous sons and  Chloe seemed to address the drama on  social media posting this pic alongside  Jeremy and his manager Jim Jordan the 26  year old daughter of billionaire Sir  Philip Green cheekily captioned the pic  just the beginning we appreciate all the  love and the hate no word on how melissa  is feeling about the love fest in the  Mediterranean I'm a little nervous but  more excited eetzi has reached out to  meets rep for comment  [Music]